welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Helene land more assistant professor
of political science her research
interests include democratic theory
theories of justice the philosophy of
social sciences and the history of
thought professor lanta Moore is
currently working on a new project on
democratic innovations in post
representative democracy
she has just published an article on the
inclusive and partly crowd-sourced
Constitution making process in Iceland
and she is involved in the design and
study of a crowd-sourced legislative
process in Finland she also is
researching the question of democracy in
the workplace today we talked with
professor land more about rethinking
democracy in the 21st century
welcome professor landmark thank you so
your recent work is working on
democratic innovations in post
representative democracy what do you
mean by that so I should think you heard
about my previous work first sort of
friend the question I my previous work
was an exploration of the connection
between the inclusiveness of our
democratic decision procedures in fact
that we try to include as many votes and
voices as possible and the ability of
those decision procedures to produce
good outcomes good laws good policy I
was doing that from a rather theoretical
formal perspective and now I'm
interested in exploring more empirically
more inductively actual experiments that
have been conducted around the globe to
include the voices of real citizens
directly in the political decision
process okay so I've been involved in I
mean I've studied and been involved in a
couple of those I've studied the
Icelandic process that had of this cart
sourcing moment in the in the key
drafting of the new constitution I've
also been involved in the design and
implementation of crowdsourcing
experiment for policymaking in Finland
in order to reform low enough road
traffic basically the
regulation of mobiles she will and
finally I've also looked at experiments
in the workplace meant to involve
workers more directly in the
decision-making process all right let's
go let's talk about Iceland first a
little bit and just what is
crowdsourcing exactly so crowdsourcing
there are many definitions in the
literature still somewhat competing
because it's a very recent what a
concept dates back to 2006 but I like to
think of it as as just outsourcing to a
crowd so that is to an agent that is
neither known or vetted nor vated xmt
contrary to what happens to begin in
classical outsourcing so you don't know
who's going to show up you don't know
their identities you don't know the
competencies you don't know the gender
you don't know anything
and it's usually a four tasks that have
to do with ID mapping problem solving
coding in some cases and it's usually
done online as well okay so the this
group of people how many typically would
it be well it's not that many you would
imagine that if you open up a platform
online you could get potentially
millions of people showing up in fact
it's usually a couple of hundred to a
few thousand maybe okay never more than
I mean at least as far as we've observed
it's between one three percent of the
population so it's usually a self select
group of very motivated people okay
and what are the specifics of the
Iceland situation so what interested me
in that experiment is that for the first
time in history really the the the
writing of the social contract of a
country was made as inclusive as
possible of actual citizens so you know
if you picture the American convention
you know in Philadelphia in 18th century
it was basically fifty five white men in
wigs an elite social political elite who
gathered you know for a few months in
secretive meetings and the people really
were asked to ratify the document you
know they they had only the option to
say yes or no but they didn't have a
chance to give their input this time
around the Restonic people
decided to do something very innovative
they at mini level this was very
innovative but crucially the the writing
of the document was partly crowd-sourced
in the sense that the 25 members of the
council council we're themselves actual
citizens not regular citizens not public
officials not appointed officials not
experts in any way wrote the draft
successive draft and posted them online
on a specific internet page and also on
a Facebook page so this is the
constitution for Iceland their rewrite
yes yes well they so they did that over
a couple of years between summer of 2010
and the spring of 2013 and unfortunately
the experiment failed because the the
Parliament shelf to draft and so it was
never passed into law but it wasn't
interesting look at the possibilities of
using crowdsourcing for various
policymaking decisions right yeah and
and in that case a foundational document
that would govern their lives
how about Finland tell us about the work
there so Finland it's a project that was
started in January 2013 and as far as
the researchers party's concern ended in
last fall and this was an attempt by the
the finished Parliament and and the
Finnish ministry for environment of
environment to crowdsource the reform on
off road traffic that there's the ATVs
ATVs and snowmobiles so casually because
they couldn't come up with a good bill
so they thought okay well why don't we
try out this you know new thing called
crowdsourcing and and asks the
snowmobilers and the property or other
land owners the two parties sort of who
are at odds with each other in this
specific law what they thought of the
law was problem with the law and how
they would go about fixing it so that we
put my colleague and co-author Tanya
item water from Berkeley University in
charge of creating a platform and
implementing a design for that for that
thing and then she bought
on board in spring last year and
together we we've been implementing the
design and studying the results okay so
by implementing the design what do you
mean well basically we really created
the platform the the the questions that
were asked we I mean she did most of the
interaction with the participants being
finished herself and then we gathered
the data on you know the kind of answers
we got the the kind of problem
identified and how they would go about
solving there and then we wrote a report
for the Finnish government so there were
three three three steps one one was
really asking people where they thought
were the problems with the law the
second was the the problem the ID
gathering for solutions and then the
last phase was actually feeding back the
solutions to the crowd and asking them
to rank and evaluate them I say okay so
that's what very interesting so how many
people participated in that process and
so the first two phase is the problem
mapping and ID mapping about 700 and the
last phase I think a little bit less but
half that I think so I am curious how do
you get those 700 people do you put an
ad in the paper how are they how does
the public know about this right well
this is partly the task of the the
Finnish Parliament and and you know
affiliated bureaucracies to sort of
advertise for that that's actually one
of the sore point both in the Icelandic
case and the Finnish case how do you get
the message across right now I think in
the Estonian case in particular the
media didn't cover it enough so that
limited participation in the Finnish
case I know that my colleague Tonya
Camacho did really a lot to get the word
across so you know you go through
associations of snowmobilers
you try to get the word out but Facebook
it federal alright so what was the
outcome so the outcome well so the
experiment is not completely over in the
sense that we are still waiting to see
if the Parliament is a Finnish Ministry
of Environment of anything with the
input we we sort of reported on
hopefully in the next few months we'll
have a sense there are a lot of
resistance is you know bureaucracies are
hard to change
so but the results as far as we are
concerned as researcher is that this the
crowd is East Mart you know they came up
with a lot of innovative ideas and when
we asked them to rank them they
typically ranked the most outrageous or
simplistic or unfair ones at the bottom
for example you know not including any
compensation scheme for landowners or
reducing the age limit for snow mobile
riding to nine year old or things like
that they came up with very interesting
ideas like for example when one that we
thought was great was using GPS devices
installed on snowmobiles to track the
most used routes and then use that sort
of Geographic you know education to
create the official roads there but it
turns out that even though it was video
clever idea we thought the when we asked
the community of the crowd to rank the
idea they didn't like that idea at all
because another thing to notice about
that experiments that of course
crowdsourcing is based on self selection
so most of the participants were
snowmobilers themselves and they have a
very libertarian ystos they don't really
want to be monitored by the government
so they don't want the data to be you
know used okay very interesting and then
the third thing you're working on is the
workplace democracy in the workplace so
tell us about that
so democracy in the workplace so one
thing I should say about the whole
project of past representative democracy
that I think it entails thinking beyond
to conceptual roadblocks one is the idea
that democracy is just about
representation you can only be indirect
in in mastema
in math societies right and I think in
fact we should rethink direct
involvement of the people not
necessarily along the lines of engine
offense but some ways the other one is
that we have this idea that democracy is
just a political concept that applies
only to you know the political sphere
narrowly defined but I think it needs to
be expanded to the economic sphere as
well in specifically the workplace so
what I'm doing with my mic Arthur Isabel
Farris from University of
on this issue is to explore the
arguments for and against democracy in
the workplace and in particular the
objections through an analogy that's
often made by advocates of democracy in
the workplace between the firm and the
state so that's that's the last project
that I'm involved in okay and tell us
about it
so we've I mean we've considered a
number of projections seven of them so
far one of them is uh I thought was
actually very compelling initially it's
got to do with the fact that you know
usually when you when you talk about
giving some control to the workers
people fire back by saying well but the
firm is the property of the shareholders
why would they you know
surrender any kind of control that's the
thing and it's a completely false
conception it turns out in in all legal
it's either shareholders only own a
certain number of rights associated with
our shares but they don't own the firm
they don't own the corporation and
besides the the the legal rights that
they have are conventionally defined
they could completely be redefined in
different ways that's what happened in
in post-war world to Germany for example
when the state imposes this regime of
mid Midwest among co-determination
in which the workers have almost an
equal say in the management of the firm
and the business decision and the
strategy as the the board of
shareholders so it's it can be
redefining so I'm going to go out on a
limb and say my guess would be many
corporations would not want to have the
workers involved in a more democratic
manner or would it be in their best
interest well I'm so using my previous
work on you know the epistemic
properties of inclusive decision-making
I would actually make the case that yes
they could benefit in what way
well they could tap the collective
intelligence of their workers I think
there's a great loss of human capital
and human intelligence in in the way in
corporations in the way that currently
organized because workers do information
retention they're not motivated why
should they care right
even a say voice so they they do the
minimum amount to get paid and get her
head to a degree okay so what does all
of this work you're doing mean in terms
of how we see democracy today when you
speak about crowdsourcing I think that's
a wonderful idea in it I think it is
great to get as many people involved in
the process as possible but then for
instance when you look at the number of
people who come out and vote for
instance it's minuscule so how do you
explain that kind of thing
right so that's a very good question yes
indeed and I think a lot of my
colleagues in political science spend a
lot of time you know criticizing the
citizens for being irrational and
uninformed and apathetic but in fact I
think it's a case of blaming the victim
because if you want the the lack of
involvement is endogenous through
institutions we have by which I mean
that people have no incentive to go out
and vote or care about politics because
their voice makes no difference we
actually it's one vote in a million plus
in in the current system at least in the
US with gerrymandering and and what
happened is that it's not the voters
selecting the representatives it's a
representatives really selecting voters
so they're doing the reasonable thing
they're staying home they don't really
have an incentive to to care and I think
this democratic innovation that I was
talking about are a way to involve them
and give them a reason to care and in
the experiment in Finland for example
we've observed that people care another
thing though to go back to the question
of how many people participate and it's
still small number and that connects to
the economic aspect of it that they
don't have time because they are busy
with their lives and they have to earn
you know a living so another part of the
reform of this positive of the the
program of the reform program that sort
of comes along with this notion of pass
representative democracy is to give back
people the time and and the opportunity
to care about politics to a degree every
day right it is very difficult to be
really up to even voting you have to try
and familiarize yourself with the
candidates right you know to understand
the
she takes amount of time so I think that
time is going to be needed for people to
make intelligent decisions right so do
you think crowdsourcing is on an upward
trend well I think it's been it's
certainly very fashionable in recent
years so the thing is we don't know
enough about it yet so that's why it's
very important to study it ok very good
thank you so much for being here with us
today and sharing some of your work
thank you so much for having me for more
information about professor Lance Moore
and her research please visit our
website at Yale edu slash Macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale